april 2011 de fortes pluies s'abattent
sur fort de france
un glissement de terrain a amorcé au
quartier morne calebasse le phénomène
qui concerne une surface de 3 ha
entraîne le 7 mai la fermeture de la
route
mais dans la nuit du 1er au 2 août une
importante coulée de boue causées par la
tempête emily conduit en pleine nuit à
l'évacuation des habitations menacées si
cet épisode a marqué les esprits
les franciscaines n'oublieront pas non
plus au quartier soleil levant le
glissement de terrain de 2004 dont les
premiers désordres ont apparu dans la
nuit du 13 au 14 novembre
là encore suite à de fortes pluies la
r10 et coupé plusieurs maisons sont
évacués je suis des ménages change de
maison jeudi visiter une maison là deux
jours déjà suite au plus de vendredi on
a été déjà pas mal touché
donc j'avais pris les devants il se
trouve que je vais
j'ai partir le plus vite possible dans
cette nouvelle maison parmi les hommes
souvent affecté la route de deux choux
10 monterrey entraînant des éboulements
souvent obstrués la chaussée en 2016
malgré des travaux qui deux ans plus tôt
avait été effectué l'accès à la route de
la traçabilité une fois de plus fermé
aux habitants de fond saint denis les
mouvements de terrain sont récurrents
martinique
ils se produisent chaque année avec une
moyenne de 2 à 5 par an et sont plus
important cas d'événement météorologique
comme de fortes pluies ou des cyclones
par le passé plusieurs victimes ont même
été recensés à la médaille en 1916
quartiers là durant de saint joseph en
1963 ou encore au jardin des plantes en
1960 à saint pierre les événements sont
si nombreux qu'il est impossible de tous
les recenser
alors si tu constates tu vois la maison
une trentaine d'événements d'ampleur ont
été déclenchées depuis les années 80 aux
mécanismes divers occasionnant des
dommages illégaux les terrains argileux
souvent gorgée d'eau à cause de pluies
diluviennes glisse occasionnant des
dégâts importants